I mean this is unbelievable the
government again runs out of cash
tomorrow which means that unless the
Senate votes for a temporary spending
bill five days six days six months to
keep the government open all but
essential government services services
will be shut down midnight Friday
Democrats and a few goofball Republicans
have decided to hold the entire funding
of the US government hostage for a deal
to give legal status to 800,000 illegal
aliens brought here as miners yes you
heard that right members of Congress
elected to represent the interests of
Americans and uphold the Constitution of
the United States have now fully exposed
themselves as nothing more than a
permanent lobby for open borders and
unending cheap labor it is a total
travesty now the president despite not
having campaigned on giving amnesty to
anyone was willing and is willing to do
a deal to help the dock of people but he
required a few basic concessions from
the party out of power the Democrats
like ending chain migration and the Visa
Lottery and funding the wall that he
promised to build Democrats not the
president walked away from the
bargaining table in an attempt to force
his hand now I was thinking about this
today do you remember who was blamed by
the media back in 2013 when a few
conservative Republicans was Ted Cruz
and Mike Lee they were the party out of
power then forced a government shutdown
or it was about Obamacare well the media
and the party in power then unanimously
blamed Republicans the president drew a
firm line that he's not going to
negotiate right but he's not going to do
it until after he gets both a clean CR
that extends the government funding
reopens the government and raised the
debt limit
I'm really afraid of these Yahoo's are
going to send us right over the cliff
well we're not for is negotiating with
people of a bomb strapped to their
chests we're not going to do that well
they were following the narrative set by
the head of the party in power back then
President Barack Obama when you have a
situation in which a faction is willing
potentially to default on US government
obligations then we are in trouble and
if they're willing to do it now they'll
be doing willing to do it later
a faction it was a faction well we have
a faction now Chuck Schumer dick Durbin
Lindsey Graham well it turns out that
Republicans weren't really heard all
that much in the 2014 midterms by that
shut down as many predicted and the only
thing most people remembered about the
Ted Cruz filibuster was this say I like
green eggs and ham I do I like them
sam-i-am
I sometimes play that to my kids at
night puts them right to sleep
I mean Democrats here though in this
certain case I'm telling you they are
playing with fire and we're seeing a
little movement tonight by Chuck Schumer
we'll get to that in just a moment a new
CBS poll that was just released shows
that even among those who support
helping the daca folks Americans do not
want to shut the government down to do
so and by the way even with all the
media disinformation out there about
what chain migration is more Americans
think immigration should be based on
merit more than family ties second
cousin twice removed
aunt uncle you know the drill well all
of that is good news for Trump so you
know what I say I say it's time to call
their bluff on this Republicans
shouldn't be cowed at all they shouldn't
be worried about a government shutdown I
say let the Democrats take their stand
and force a shutdown of the government
for illegal immigrants then the American
voters will finally see once and for all
what the Democrats and amnesty fanatics
really think that the hopes and
well-being and dreams of American
citizens just aren't as important as the
potential vote that they're going to get
by an influx of illegal
and speaking of exposing the truth
Republicans in the House have finally
seen the contents of that house Intel
report on the fusion GPS dossier and the
Muller Special Counsel investigation and
apparently it is a blockbuster sources
are telling the Ingraham angle that the
contents paint a disturbing picture of
misdeeds and corruption inside the Obama
FBI which runs straight into the heart
of the special counsels office and as of
now the report is secret but many
members of Congress are asking the
speaker speaker Ryan to move to
declassify the document and release its
contents the intelligence memo that we
have just read is so alarming that it
must be immediately disclosed to the
American people I couldn't agree more at
that point Speaker Ryan should cut
through whatever bureaucratic protocol
is necessary to see that the contents of
this report are made public let's let's
remove all doubt about what's in that
report and I'll tell you this if it
turns out that our FBI has been
compromised and that American citizens
have been targeted for surveillance for
purely political reasons or that the
Obama Justice Department and maybe even
some in the White House we're in on it
boy do the people have a right to know
and they have a right to know now not
six weeks from now and not six months
from now remember this dossier this
fusion GPS dossier was a campaign
generated document paid for by the
Democrats and if it was used to justify
spying on anyone associated with Donald
Trump heads should roll it's time to
expose this entire circus to the
sunlight all of us should be able to
trust federal law enforcement to be
objective and certainly not filled with
some vengeful political hack them
we all deserve that and in this case of
course the president and anyone else in
robert muller sites they deserve it too
and that's the angle